>>> TONIT AN ONSLAUGHT OF
MISSILES, DOZENS OF TH RAINING
DOWN ON UKRAINE LEAVING NEARLY
HALF OF UKRAINIANS WITH NO POWER
IN THE COLD AND DARK.
EACH MISSILE DELIVERING
DESTRUCTION AND DEATH.
JUST LOOK AT THIS TO ACCEPTS
THEIR DARK POWER.
THIS APPEARS TO BE THE MOMENT
TWO CRUZ MISSILES WAS SHOT DOWN
OVER KYIV.
WATCH THIS FOR YOURSELF.
WE CAN'T VERIFY THE AUTHENTICITY
OF THIS.
>> HEARD AN EXPLOSION.
>> THIS IS IT.
THIS IS IT.
>> HELL.
>> DID IT EXPLODE?
>> YES, IT'S AN EXPLOSION.
>> A MISSILE?
>> YES.
>> [ BLEEP ].
[ BLEEP ].
>> CAN'T SEE THEM SHOOTING THEM
DOWN.
>> WE CAN'T EVEN SEE WHAT'S
SHOOTING THEM DOWN.
>> THEY ARE REALLY GOOD AT
AMBUSH.
>> YOU SEE THAT SECOND MISSILE,
THAT SPEED WITH WHICH IT MOVES.
SHOT DOWN BY UKRAINIAN AIR
DEFENSE.
THIS IS WHAT HAPPENED WHEN A
MISSILE HIT POLE LAPPED.
UKRAINIAN PRESIDENT ZELENSKYY
SAYS HE WANTS TO KNOW WHAT
HAPPENED.
CNN HAS LEARNED THAT BIDEN'S
NATIONAL SECURITY ADVISER JAKE
SULLIVAN CALLED ZELENSKYY'S
OFFICE TO TELL HIM TO TREAD MORE
CAREFULLY.
EARLIER THIS MORNING AS
PRESIDENT BIDEN RETURNED FROM
BALI HE HAD THIS TO SAY ABOUT
ZELENSKYY'S ORIGINAL CLAIMS.
>> WHAT'S YOUR REACTION TO
PRESIDENT ZELENSKYY SAYING THAT
THE MISSILES THAT LANDED IN POIL
LAND WERE NOT UKRAINIAN?
>> THAT'S NOT THE EVIDENCE.
>>> "OUT FRONT" NOW THE RETIRED
ARMY GENERAL JAMES SPIDER MARKS.
I WANT TO START WITH YOU WITH
THE REPORTING.
I HOPE THIS STUCK WITH PEOPLE.
WE'RE REPORTING THE U.S. IS
RUNNING LOW ON ADVANCED WEAPONS
AND AMMUNITION SYSTEMS, SYSTEMS
UKRAINE WANTS.
U.S. HAS BEEN SUPPLYING SOME OF
THEM.
WE UNDERSTAND NOW FROM U.S.
OFFICIALS THE SUPPLIES ARE
DWINDLING.
NO SURPRISE THE DEPARTMENT OF
DEFENSE WHEN THEY HEARD THIS,
READINESS WON'T BE IMPACTED.
THIS IS PRETTY JARRING.
WHAT IS THE RISK HERE?
>> WELL, THERE'S A SIGNIFICANT
RISK, ERIN.
WHEN YOU LOOK AT IT, THE
SUPPLIES THAT THE UNITED STATES
HAS IS BASED ON A NUMBER OF
CALCULATIONS, YOU KNOW, HOW MANY
THEATER ENGAGEMENTS CAN THEY
AFFORD, ET CETERA.
THIS POPPED UP.
THIS WAS NOT ONE OF THEM AND
SUDDENLY THIS BECAME THE MOST
IMPORTANT THING WE WERE DOING.
THE STOCKPILES CAME DOWN.
WE'RE NOT SURPRISED.
IN FACT, JUST RECENTLY THERE WAS
A PLUS UP, A FUNDING PLUS UP TO
MAKE SURE WE HAD THE HIGH MAR,
THE HIGH MOBILITY ARTILLERY
ROCKET SYSTEM.
WE HAD TO INCREASE THE AMOUNT OF
AMMUNITION.
THE SUPPLIES ARE NECESSARILY
GOING TO DECREASE.
THIS IS AN INEVITABILITY.
THE PROBLEM THAT COMES IS YOU
LOOK ACROSS ALL THE NATO
NATIONS.
THEY ARE INCREASING THEIR
SUPPORT.
THEY HAVE A CHALLENGE.
NATO REQUIREMENTS AND THEY HAVE
A DECREASE IN SUPPLIES.
ACROSS THE BOARD EVERYBODY IS
FEELING THE PAIN.
>> OBVIOUSLY, IT'S DEEPLY
CONCERNING.
WE ARE HEARING FROM UKRAINIAN
MILITARY SOURCES, THEY'RE SAYING
PUTIN IS INCREASING THE NUMBER
OF CRUZ MISSILE CARRIERS IN THE
BLACK SEA TO THREE.
THEY HAVE IRANIAN SUPPLY COMING
ONLINE.
THAT WOULD BE, YOU KNOW, REALLY
TRIPLING THEIR LAUNCH CAPACITY
FOR THE BLACK SEA.
WHAT DOES THIS MEAN FOR THE WAR?
>> WELL, SIGNIFICANTLY WHEN I
LOOK AT THIS, I LOOK AT THE
BLACK SEA AND THE BLACK SEA IS
SIMPLY A BATHTUB.
THERE IS NO PLACE TO HIDE IN THE
BLACK SEA AND THERE'S ONLY ONE
EXIT AND ONLY ONE ENTRANCE.
SO WHAT RUSSIA DOES THERE, WHAT
THE UNITED STATES DOES THERE AND
FRANKLY THAT'S WHY THE UNITED
STATES CURRENTLY DOESN'T HAVE A
LARGE PRESENCE IN THE BLACK SEA,
OUR U.S. NAVY DOESN'T LIKE GOING
IN THERE FOR THAT ONE REASON,
WHY RUSSIA IS INCREASING ITS HE
PRESENCE IS BEYOND MY MIND.
THEY CAN LAUNCH CRUZ MISSILES
FROM THE DNC.
I DON'T UNDERSTAND.
UKRAINIANS HAVE HAD A PRETTY
GOOD TRACK RECORD GOING AFTER
THOSE PRESENT IN THE BLACK SEA.
>> RIGHT.
THANK YOU SO MUCH, GENERAL.
AS ALWAYS, I APPRECIATE YOU.